ladies and gentlemen
it is 2022. yes welcome to the first
show of the year on tim cast irl and
this is an election year it is a a main
election year 2020 was a the biggest
election year
2019 was the primary season 2018 was the
midterms
2021 is when everyone is just
zoned out they are they're beaten down
and tired
2022
the house
the senates
they're at stake
and we are there there are predictions
from many pollsters
many analysts of a red tsunami
now it's not just that people are sick
and tired of democrats that independent
voters are favoring republicans in the
double digits it's that gerrymandering
also just happened redistricting
happened and now there's an expectation
that all of these republican-controlled
states because people were voting in
their local elections have set it up so
that republicans are more likely to win
combined with the fact that we have a
massive number of democrats retiring fox
news reports
surge in house democratic 2022
retirement announcements as 2021 comes
to a close
they say a trio of democrats in the
house reps uh stephanie murphy of
florida lucille roybal ellard of
california and albio cyrus of new jersey
last week said they'll they'll retire at
the end of next year rather than run in
the 2022 midterm elections for another
term in congress the latest news brought
to uh 23 the number of house democrats
who are retiring or bidding for another
office we just got news that i think was
it bobby rush
is also not going to be seeking
reelection there's actually an
announcement from a bunch of democrats
who had lost in 2018 who were going to
try and run again also now announcing
they're not going to bother trying to
run even though they aren't in office
something is happening
i think the democrats see the writing on
the wall nobody wants to be that losing
candidate so they're like what's the
point if you can't win do something else
a bunch of these democrats are running
for other offices you know in the state
governorships or whatever many are just
bowing out
i don't know man red wave what do you
think
it seems like if the election were held
you know next week that would be the
case right
uh the question i think is
can the democrats instill some
confidence on issues like what's
happening in the economy what's
happening with covet i think biden's
biden's mandate was basically normalcy
right can he create a normal political
social and economic environment and i
think part of that is like
getting past the pandemic part of that
is getting past cobia 19 and i think
there's people within his political
party that really don't want to do that
they're not ready for that i think
they've inculcated a certain mindset
among a lot of the democrats on kobe 19
that it's just very hard to overcome
even though there are signs that i think
the bite administration is pushing in
that direction i don't think they're
going to be look i i hate to say i know
what's going to happen i don't based on
everything we've seen with the polls
i think it's fairly likely the democrats
they know what's happening the writing's
on the wall but i want to show you you
mentioned joe biden i want to show you
this meme that's been going around i did
not make this yeah it says 2020 biden
harris every single covet death is
someone donald trump murdered 2021 joe
biden eating an ice cream cone there's
nothing i can do jack
that's where we're at
joe biden the democrat look i think the
democrats uh voters they voted for biden
because they hate trump without trump
they have no identity that was their
whole rally their whole rallying cry was
orange man bad and now there's nothing
going into the midterms you've got
parents who are livid you've got an
economy in shambles you've got joe biden
saying there's nothing we can do at the
federal level well i'll tell you this
you you vote in the primaries and get
rid of all the established republicans
bring in some populists who believe in
america they'll bring your jobs back
they'll secure your borders they'll make
sure the country's economy is getting
back on track
i don't necessarily have anything to say
about an individual candidate but i'll
tell you the democrats ain't gonna do it
they have become the party of big
business massive corporate wealth you
take a look at people like hassan [ __ ]
who is one of the most prominent voices
among progressives and he supports the
government mandating you be administered
a private product from a massive
multinational unaccountable corporation
with no liability protections and i
don't care what the dude says he claims
about you know i don't care what his
claims are about supporting universal
health care and nationalization of big
pharma it's like dude you're sitting
here right now telling us that you want
the government government to be able to
mandel mandate a private product to be
administered to people if they want to
engage in public in public
accommodations if they want to be able
to use these things i'm sorry this is
what the modern left is this is you know
he he's one of the one of the if not the
biggest political commentator on the
left and that's what young leftists
follow support for that kind of system
not always not everybody who watches
likes him i get that but that to me is
insane i can sit here all day and say
that a lot of trump supporters are in a
cult and and you know worship the ground
trump walks on i can say that donald
trump is he represents the worst of
american culture and my opinion i can
say he had a lot of really good policies
and as much as a lot of people didn't
like him for who he was he was actually
bringing factories back he was trying to
secure america's borders and bolster our
economy so people whether they liked him
or not they voted for him there are
certainly a lot of people who love him
we're not getting that from the
establishment the democrats are offering
us nothing other than trump is bad and
people they're like i don't know
anything about that at the point trump's
not the president the economy is in
shambles my life is not going well i'm
tired of the lockdowns they just brought
back mass mandates down the street
because we're on the border of the
county and it makes literally no sense
and i'm like these people need to be
stripped of all power they are
completely insane and that is the
democratic party and the republican
establishment
so one of the things i noticed what are
the things i think the democrats really
should have done and then i have a
question for you um is
they should have run on getting rid of
trump because that's pretty strong
platform and the first thing they should
have done is turn and said we have to
have issues that we're fighting for not
just stuff that we're fighting against
because it's not a winning strategy in
the long term they had to have known
this i just don't think they were
thinking anywhere near far enough past
stage one and then for you in your um
meme here you use the term mass
formation psychosis and i haven't really
been able to get into this but i keep
seeing it can you like unpack that for
us well i i i just use that phrase in
reference to uh it's a cult it's a cult
that that's formed oh okay i've long
said that they're a chaotic and
destructive force the left i don't like
the idea of uh i've actually been
critical of those it's critical race
theory over and over again because
what's happening on the left isn't just
critical race theory that's why i like
to say wokeness or something it is oh
all of these things are just an amalgam
of contrarian i hate the other that's
our identity there you know it's really
funny you look at reddit you look at the
comments and they'll say all the trump
cult they just hate the other side it's
like who are you listening to who are
you watching because if you watch like i
don't know steven crowder one of the
most prominent independent conservative
voices he's actually making arguments
right he doesn't just hate you in fact
he tries to debate you to bring you on
and convince you to change my mind who
are they actually listening to oh cnn
brian stelter jake tapper cuomo while
he's gone things like that mass
formation psychosis in my view i'm just
referencing all of these people
they they their world was was was
getting crazy social media was crazy
they latched on to this narrative that
trump was the cause of all of it and you
were mentioning something earlier that
michael malus said they thought donald
trump was the was the river when he was
actually the dam yeah i messaged you i
said that one of the most insightful
things that i think i've ever heard of
modern political commentators say is
something michael mal said and that was
they thought that
um trump was the river wait what was it
he said they thought trump was the river
but he was actually the damn yes so that
means that he was kind of holding back
this huge wave of populism um he was
really just the tip of the iceberg which
is something that they weren't counting
on and now i think they're seeing the
other side of that when donald trump
goes on stage with bill o'reilly and he
gets booed by his audience it's not a
cult right it is it is angry people they
are america first individuals they are
fed up with all of this
i think the democrats know all of this
all right all right hot shots pop quiz
name
a democrat who could win a presidential
election who's relative like right now
name somebody i've been thinking about
that
yeah oprah michelle obama yeah michelle
michelle obama oprah actively right now
in politics right now in politics who's
who's a prominent oh sure trump was
never in politics either right trump
trump was planning on running he just he
ran a number of times he lost right
before yeah it's it's so i'll be the
first to say i've stated before i think
michelle obamacare i don't think i don't
think i don't think she can at this
point i do not think so really but
obviously michelle obama because if you
take a celebrity
and you know put them in a position they
might get the votes but like i'm i mean
like who among democrats right now i
mean oprah oprah's a tv show they don't
have a bench right right they have not
developed because their leadership is so
old
they have a young generation but those
young generation are way too young right
like people in their early 30s are not
going to be running for president right
so they don't have that middle layer of
people of kind of like statesmen and
states women who could just jump into
the presidential spot and you know the
typically in this scenario you'd line up
the vice president but nobody likes the
vice president yep she's even more
unpopular than joe biden is right and
actually i think that flipped recently
oh did it okay yeah yeah i think i think
his approval dropped below hers it's so
bad
that's really bad worse oh my gosh
so i
i think common 2022 the democrats have
awakened to the reality without
trump
they have nothing well look i and the
right doesn't need trump i i live in
virginia i did some reporting on the
election
and at one point i got a mailer from the
democratic party of virginia about glen
younkin the republican candidate and it
was full of trump quotes about glenn
younkin it was just talking about how
trump has endorsed junk and how much he
likes duncan didn't say anything about
the democratic candidate didn't really
say anything about yunkan himself just
talked about trump
mcauliffe the democratic candidate for
governor who lost kept talking about
trump every other line out of his mouth
was trump trump trump
that's their motivating fact right they
they you know it's the dog running after
the car they caught the car
trump is gone but
that's still their campaigns that's
still their focus is trump and the
problem is that that might work for the
hardcore democratic faithful but a lot
of these people in between the hispanics
the wall street journal had a really
good article about hispanics are now
like split between the parties uh we had
roy tahera on our podcast on
inquiremoor.com who was one of the
emerging democratic
majority author whose uh thesis has been
badly misinterpreted he was saying it's
not true that just because you know
america is going to have many more
minorities the democrats are
automatically going to win because
hispanics care about issues like
you know basic bread and butter issues
and they care about they don't want to
defund police they don't want kind of a
radical social agenda you know these are
very middle middle of the road type
voters and i think these middle of road
type voters you know just being against
one person for the rest of their life
donald trump is not a motivation to vote
right getting things basically working
in their lives is the motivation to vote
and the democrats really aren't doing
that when there's a permanent coven
coveted emergency they just can't
overcome right and they have to either
admit it's what they're doing doesn't
work and that they've wasted your time
or that it's over and they lose that
emergency you know power that fear
factor i'll tell you i'll tell you what
i care about for one the economy is
trash inflation is through the roof and
we need to get this country working
again the current policies are our
disaster but i also want to mention the
insanity of it all so this past weekend
i was with my girlfriend we went to go
with sushi
we walk into this restaurant which is i
kid you not the the restaurant is
probably about as big as two of this
studio room so that's like you know 15
by 35 the restaurant was probably like
15 by 50 or something there was a table
about 10 feet away from where we were
standing we walk up the stairs and
there's a waiter he's wearing a mask and
he sees us he goes you have masks and we
were like no we don't have any like
there's the mask mandate literally came
back the day before yeah it was at 5 00
p.m on december 31st so we're there on
like you know new year's day or whatever
like you know we're gonna grab some
sushi like no we don't have any and he's
like well you need to wear them and then
i look around and i see 20 people
sitting down and i'm like nobody's
wearing a mask
like they're all sitting here and they
were like well they're sitting down and
i was like all right can i can we just
sit down like there's a table literally
10 feet in front of us and he was like
yes but you have to have a mask and i
was like
but no one is wearing one like there's
they're all talking they're all laughing
they're all eating and they're not
wearing masks but i was i was like okay
no i i get it we'll sit down and he says
fine but if you get up you have to have
a mask so he hands us masks and say okay
no problem i don't care and then he's
grabbing the menus to take the two
seconds to walk us to our seat when all
of a sudden behind the counter my right
i hear someone yell put the mask on wow
and then i was like we're gonna sit down
like no you have to wear it and then i
was like but i can take it off when i
sit down they're like yes and i went are
you serious and they all all the staff
go yes and i was like dude i am out of
here man
like
there is a certain degree to where when
all this started they said mask mandates
i'm like i get it man
masks stop you from spitting on people
they don't stop the aerosolized virus to
my understanding but spinning on people
can also transmit so that i get that
makes sense to me but when you're in a
restaurant and they're like take this
disposable mask you're gonna throw away
in 30 seconds we don't actually expect
you to wear it while you're here but you
have to pretend to be doing something
for some reason i'm like dude why are
you doing this this is going beyond
insane
and that is something that frederick
county and uh there's a couple counties
in in maryland are doing new york has va
has vax or mask as a statewide policy
now and i'm like look if you want to go
to record store i i understand that
argument but if you don't have logic
behind your policies then you are
cowards you are insane and this doesn't
make any sense so i'll tell you this if
the democrats are going to keep running
on ridiculous and not to mention
polluting policies that that are just
insane we're environmentalists we don't
like global warming but take this piece
of trash you're going to throw away and
not actually wear like they handed me
garbage they literally hand me garbage
to sit down and throw in the trash yep
that was it for no other reason yeah so
you know we did we got in the car we
drove only a few minutes because we're
on a it's a border county and then there
we were eating sushi with no mask like
what is wrong with these people man
that's what i'm sick of i'm sick of the
democrats like aoc she's in new york and
she says kathy hoechel maybe she could
give ronda santa some tips oh is that
true aoc you flew down to miami to party
with no mask on
while saying that ending the mask
mandate in texas was going to get people
killed and then you think ron desantis
needs tips yo you're going down you
don't believe in your own policies but
the cult members in your state don't
read they don't pay attention and they
vote for people like you i'm sick of it
man vote them all out but i'll tell you
this if you don't vote in the primaries
you will get a bunch of neocon crackpots
who the first thing they do is they go
now that we've been elected we're going
to stand by the mandate of the american
people and re-invade afghanistan and
great that's exactly what the people
want but just really quickly you don't
get it
the the masks work so well the first
time the covet policies worked so well
the first time that we just have to do
them again okay you know you know what i
was thinking maybe maybe it's because we
only wore two masks maybe we should wear
four that's right yeah well i think you
brought up a good point though and that
the republicans could fall into the same
trap now which is that they could see
the democratic governance is unpopular
they could see the economic and public
health emergency is kind of unpopular
they could ride that wave into power and
then they could just do nothing right i
mean that's kind of what they did uh in
2018 with healthcare right they didn't
have a healthcare strategy for the
affordable care act they they were the
dog running after the car they were
saying repeal obamacare or peel
obamacare said that for basically eight
years once they got in the position to
do something about healthcare they
didn't have any ideas uh they basically
said it's too complicated and they
couldn't agree on anything right
the question is are they actually going
to have a governing agenda or they're
going to end up right back in the same
place with parties trading places and
not actually being able to to resolve
some of these things and move forward
yeah i have absolutely no hope in the
republicans to me they're going to be
absolutely lame ducks they're going to
be sitting on their hands and they're
going to allow a lot of these egregious
behaviors to happen just like they did
from the very beginning of this so to
expect them to do something different is
absolutely naive big tech monopoly
lobbying has a hold of a lot of the big
conservative base they're absolutely
futile to actually challenge the
establishment and the few ones that do
they're the ones that get hit they're
the ones that get slandered they're the
ones that get uh you know from their
committees exactly you know progressives
just run amok in congress so you know
what's happening right now is also
absolutely crazy when we look at the raw
numbers
especially with people on twitter making
the case that you know there's huge
numbers of cases in florida going up and
only concentrating on that and ignoring
the fact that there's a lot more cases
in new york and new york of course
represents the state that did the most
what's the correct answer here
uh it's a very complicated one it's not
an easy one but i i would end by saying
you shouldn't have all of your faith all
of your cookies and that republican
basket because you're going to be let
down or or just vote in the primaries
and make sure you get rid of the
establishment thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you